hey this is really funny
um it this is not the the biggest news
story but Ted Cruz went to Yankee
Stadium a place I've spent many many
hours at and uh he was at Yankee Stadium
because the Houston Astros Texas
baseball team are playing against the
New York Yankees and everything about it
is just completely humiliating at one
point Ted Cruz cheering for the wrong
team but the funniest part is actually
something that has dramatically improved
my opinion of Yankees fans I've been to
many you you know I grew up in
Massachusetts I'm a Red Sox fan but I've
gone to many many games uh at Yankee
Stadium when the Red Sox come to town
and I you know never cause any trouble
or anything like that but trouble
sometimes Finds Its way to Yankee
Stadium uh during big rivalries and I
have to tell you that I just love love
love the Yankee fans here here they are
noticing that Ted Cruz is coming in
listen to the treatment he gets
us
[Applause]
yeah so really getting the full
treatment there from the Yankee fans
also another really funny moment
um in this in this clip you're going to
see
the Yankees pitcher strikes out the
Houston batter and you see Ted Cruz
wearing a bright orange shirt and a vest
right behind home plate he cheers at the
guy he's supposed to be rooting for
striking out Cruz doesn't know what's
going on uh uh I'm gonna play this
actually without audio you can see here
in comes the pitch and then it's in
there for a called third strike and Ted
Cruz cheers
[Laughter]
oh dear God he is just the worst and
then here is another little quick video
of Ted Cruz
um leaving and again getting getting the
full treatment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go back to Cancun now more substantly
substantively in terms of New York City
Ted Cruz voted against hurricane Aid uh
after Hurricane Sandy ravaged New York
and New Jersey back in 2012 and then in
2017 after Hurricane Harvey crushed
Houston he was saying give us money give
us money give us money and when you ask
him aren't you a hypocrite he was like
oh no no Sandy was all pork none of the
money went to the victims which of
course was not true he's horrible truly
horrible